I want you to look at the toString method that I added to this class. You can
use toString to print out all of the scores. It might help if you find that you
need to debug a bit. It's also worth spending a moment to look at this
carefully. The arrays class has a lot of useful methods for working with
arrays. It's structured a little bit like the math class. So to use these
methods you call Arrays.toString or Arrays.copyOf. Now, if I call
Arrays.toString, and I just gave it the scores, which is a partially filled
array, it would print out a whole lot of zeroes at the end. And I'm not really
couting those as part of my array right now. So I need to trim down the array
first. I'm using Arrays.copyOf, to trim down the array. Arrays.copyOf takes the
array that you want to copy and the desired new length. So this method call
makes a shorter array that is a copy of the original and then when I pass that
to arrays toString it will now return a string representation of only the part
of scores that i am interested in